Let's think a
little bit about why
credit default
swaps, or famously
referred to by Warren
Buffett as financial weapons
of mass destruction.
At the center of
it-- and there's
not just one credit
default swap writer,
but I'll put one in the
middle because each of them
are writing many, many
credit default swaps.
AIG is the most famous.
But you have some writer here.
They're given some
good credit rating.
Maybe in the past
that credit rating
was actually earned by
a credit rating agency.
And then frankly, the
credit rating agency
got a little sloppy and really
wasn't willing to downgrade
them given all of
the credit default
swaps, all of the obligations
they are taking on.
And as you could tell, I kind of
view these guys and these guys
as the main culprits,
and maybe a little bit
of the regulatory agencies
saying, hey, look,
these guys are
writing insurance.
Maybe we should
actually regulate them.
But with that said, you
have companies over here.
I'll do the companies
in this pink color.
And they want to borrow
money from other parties,
let's say, investors.
I'll do the investors
in this orange color.
So the investors are
lending them money.
The companies give
them interest.
So investors lending money,
giving interest, lending money,
giving interest, lending
money, giving interest.
And then these investors--
it seems pretty reasonable--
say, hey, look, there's a
guy over here with a double A
rating.
The people that we're lending
to don't have a double A rating.
Maybe this guy has a B, maybe
this guy has a double B,
maybe this guy only has a
single A. And so he says, look,
I want to be
completely safe here
so I'm going to pay a
little bit of a premium
to AIG or to the writer,
whoever the writer is,
and in exchange I will get
insurance on this debt.
And it seems pretty
reasonable except for the fact
that this player right over here
did not put out any money aside
or did not put the
appropriate amount of money
aside to properly account for
all of these liabilities, all
of this risk that its taking on.
And also, all of these
risks are correlated.
You can imagine a situation
where the economy goes bad.
Now, all of a sudden
this company defaults
on its debt and this company
defaults on its debt.
In fact, when the
economy's good,
it's likely that very
few of these companies
are going to default and
when the economy goes bad,
it's likely that many
of them will default.
But the real problem is is as
soon as these defaults start
happening, then the
credit default swap writer
is going to have to actually
start paying for the defaults.
They'll get the bad debt
and in exchange they'll
make the other side
of the credit default
swap, the holder of it, they
will pay to make them whole.
And so this could take
them out of business.
And all of a sudden,
the people over here
who thought that they had
insurance no longer do.
And they might
actually say, wait,
I can only hold double A
debt and they might actually
have to dump this
debt on to the market.
Even worse, you have all
of the people over here
who didn't lend any
money to anybody,
but they really just
wanted to make side bets.
Either the side bets might
have been pure directional bets
on the state of
the economy saying,
hey, I think a
bunch of companies
or I think this
company in particular
is going to default on
its debt, and they too
could get credit default swaps
really as just side bets.
So just for maybe this right
here is $1 billion in debt,
maybe all of these parties
took side bets on this guy.
So even though there's only
$1 billion of debt here,
there might be $4
or $5 or $10 billion
worth of insurance on
that $1 billion bet.
So if all of a sudden
this one company
can't pay its $1 billion,
now AIG is on the line
not for $1 billion, but
for $4 or $5 or $6 billion,
however much it insured it for.
So it allows people
to insure for things
that they don't have the
offsetting liability for.
And so you can imagine,
some of these people--
if this guy fails will just take
a loss and that's bad and all
of the rest because they
were expecting that they
wouldn't-- but some of
these players might have had
offsetting hedges.
The only reason why they
might have felt comfortable
taking on some
other liability is
they said, look, if the
economy goes really bad,
I have this insurance over here.
And they did that transaction
with another third party.
Now all of a sudden,
if the economy goes bad
and these guys say, hey,
look, I'm in a lot of trouble.
Good thing I have this
credit default swap,
but then it turns out that they
don't because the counterparty
here fails, the credit
default swap writer,
now all of a sudden this
guy becomes insolvent.
But this guy was dependent
on this guy paying
and he thought he was good
because he even looked
at this guy's books and said
this guy had offsetting hedges,
and now this guy might fail.
And so you could have
this entire cascade
through the entire
financial system.